démocrate la présidente mes chers
collègues la semaine dernière les jeunes
femmes iraniennes retirant leur voile
dans leur établissement scolaire nous
ont impressionné par leur courage et
leur détermination
ces actes de bravoure force notre
admiration et nous inspire en cette
journée internationale des droits des
filles il nous questionne il nous
rappelle qu'il reste encore beaucoup à
faire pour les filles dans le monde une
fille sur cinq a subi un viol ou une
agression sexuelle et chaque année plus
de 12 millions de filles sont mariés de
force soit un mariage forcé toutes les
deux secondes en France
82% des femmes ont été victimes de
harcèlement de rue avant l'âge de 17 ans
et pour une femme sur six l'entrée dans
la sexualité se fait pas un rapport non
consenti et non désiré
ces chiffres nous montrent nous le
montre les jeunes filles sont
particulièrement victimes de violences
et d'agressions physiques ou
psychologique ces violences laissent le
plus souvent des marques indélébiles des
cicatrices qui entravent le
développement des filles durant la
précédente législature nous avons avancé
plusieurs lois votées protègent mieux
nos enfants mais il nous reste tant à
faire j'ai la conviction que c'est par
la connaissance de leurs droits que nos
enfants et en particulier les filles
pourront s'épanouir dans notre société
alors l'éducation civique et l'éducation
sexuelle doivent devenir des
incontournables des programmes scolaires
pour que chaque enfant apprenne à se
comporter dans le respect de soi et des
autres
chaque jeune fille doit pouvoir savoir
qu'elle a le droit de dire non qu'elle
est libre d'être qui elle est fier de
revendiquer ses droits fier de s'engager
et fier de choisir son parcours de vie
madame la ministre
Elisabeth Rome je souhaiterais donc
connaître les prochaines étapes de votre
action pour permettre à toutes les
filles de notre pays d'être pleinement
maîtresse de leur destin